STEPHANIE HANNON: Woo!
OK, we are super excited
to have you here today.
We are the panel, the Bay Area
Impact Challenge Finalists.
And we'll talk in a minute
about what that means.
But first, we really want
to get to know our audience.
It helps the panelists
know a little bit
about who's in the room.
So if you can raise
your hand if you
live within 1,000 miles
of the Moscone Center.
Wait, 1,000 was too big.
100 miles.
OK, great.
How many came from
somewhere outside of the US?
Great.
How many currently
work at a nonprofit?
OK, great.
We have, it looks like,
three plus the panelists.
How many volunteer
at a nonprofit?
OK, cool.
How many people
think their team's
going to win the World Cup?
Really?
Shout out your country.
What are you guys?
AUDIENCE: America.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Anyone else?
OK, we don't have enthusiastic--
ERIC LUKOFF: I don't
even know who's playing.
STEPHANIE HANNON: OK.
Did you know the US
lost this morning?
SUSAN MERNIT: Yeah.
ERIC LUKOFF: I had no idea.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Well, my name is
Stephanie Hannon.
And I'm very proud
to be here hosting
the discussion with the Bay
Area Impact Challenge Finalists.
If some of you were
here this morning,
you might have heard
my intro already.
I'm the Director of Product for
a team called Social Impact.
And it's a really
unique, awesome place
to work at Google.
We get to apply our
engineering talent
to social and
humanitarian problems,
like how do you
improve democracy?
How do you get people
engaged with their community?
How do you make the
nonprofit ecosystem work
more efficiently?
How do you help
keep people safe?
And how do you end
repressive censorship?
So incredibly high
magnitude of challenges.
But it's really amazing
to be at a company that
invests their resources
and people in this.
From the talk this
morning, you're
going to see some
themes that carry over
into this panel about how you
think about scaling your impact
as you're a nonprofit, and also
how, when you try to address
underserved communities,
they might use technology
different than we expect.
So the Google Impact
Challenge, it's
a challenge that finds and
funds the best nonprofits
for a country and region
that are using technology
to create change
in our community.
We've hosted them in
the UK, India, Brazil,
and most recently, the Bay Area.
In March, we launched
the Bay Area one here,
asking local nonprofits to share
their most innovative idea.
Over 1,000 applied.
And we selected 25 finalists.
And we're going to talk to
three of them here today.
Across the program, we
gave away $5 million.
So lots of opportunity
for funding here.
I'm joined on this panel
by these three finalists.
The first is Eric.
Eric is the co-founding CTO of
One Degree, a nonprofit working
to revolutionize
the way low income
families access social services.
He has been a former
product manager and engineer
at Change.org.
He has worked for nonprofits
for campaigns and fundraising
efforts.
And he's been programming
since he was six years old.
He loves dogs and has a
15-year-old dog named Barkley.
I made them all
give me fun facts.
Fun facts, dogs,
if you guys want
to talk about that in the Q&A.
Susan is the CEO and Founder
of Hack the Hood, a nonprofit
addressing digital equity
by training low income
kids to create websites
for local small businesses,
actively supporting them to
launch their tech careers.
She is a former tech executive.
She was a VP at Netscape and AOL
and a senior product director
at Yahoo.
And her fun fact is that she's
an active permaculturist.
And it took me a while
to learn how to say that.
Permaculturist.
OK, Stefan is a founding member
of the Technology Advisory
Board for Beyond 12,
a nonprofit created
to increase the number of
traditionally underserved
students who earn
a college degree.
He's our international panelist.
He's from Sweden.
He moved here in '99.
He's been leading teams that
build software and design
systems for 20 years,
including at Dell.
And he's launched several
companies himself.
His fun fact is that he
loves pickled herring.
And I can tell you,
it is terrible.
Because I have had it.
So we're going to start
with an introduction.
Then I'm going to
ask a few questions.
And then we're going to
turn it over to you guys
to see what you
want to talk about.
So you can always have questions
percolating in your mind.
So to begin with,
if you can talk
about your organization,
the mission, what you're
trying to address,
and some of what
inspired you to work in this
area, starting with Eric.
ERIC LUKOFF: Great.
Thank you, Stephanie.
So I'm Eric.
I'm the CTO of One Degree.
And let's start with a little
background about something
you already probably know about.
It's really easy to find the
best burrito in the Mission.
It's really easy to make a
reservation on Open Table.
But low income families don't
have the same sorts of tools
to easily and quickly
find the services
that they need that can help
them improve their lives.
And so for example, we've
built One Degree for Angela.
Angela is a low income teenager
living in San Francisco's Outer
Sunset neighborhood.
And Angela's family
is low income.
Her parents didn't
go to college.
And they just don't
know where to send her,
or they don't have any
recommendations for her
in terms of gaining
valuable college experience.
So Angela used One Degree to
find a summer program that
is specifically
geared towards her,
under-resourced teenagers
living in the Bay Area,
to help them gain work
experience to make
them more competitive
for college.
And so we're helping Angela.
But we're also helping
lots of families
with lots of different sorts of
needs, in health, in housing,
in food, and all kinds
of social services.
And the reason it's so difficult
to navigate the social safety
net is because
there's over 6,000
in the Bay Area,
6,000 nonprofits
doing social service work.
And just doing a Google
search doesn't really work.
Because it just gives you
back thousands of links.
You don't know what
you're eligible for.
You don't know what's
actually a good fit for you.
You don't know actually
what each organization does.
STEPHANIE HANNON: We know.
ERIC LUKOFF: You know-- yeah.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Search
quality is challenging.
ERIC LUKOFF: Right.
And I'm not sure that just
improving search quality
would even get at the issue.
We have online directories
of social services.
Even if you limit it down to
a pool of organizations that
is somewhat finite, you still
are stuck with this issue of,
OK, what am I eligible for?
What do organizations do?
Getting at the heart of
that issue is the key.
And so with One Degree, for
example, I've illustrated here,
nonprofit social
work professionals
have been using paper
binders for generations.
And in some cases,
we've put those online.
But those are just basically
glorified paper binders online.
And so we can do better.
And so here's what we've
done with One Degree.
We've created a website
that helps you find really
specific, actionable information
that we call opportunities.
So when you search
on One Degree,
we don't just give you
back the organization.
We give you back the
thing that you can do.
So for instance, get
job training for adults,
or get a free hot meal
on Thursday evenings
at this location at this time.
And then the second
thing that we
do with One Degree
is we help you manage
those resources, the things
that you think will help you.
And so we keep track
of those in a list.
We send you personalized
recommendations.
And then we're extremely
metrics driven.
And we are able to track
what's relevant to you
and what you take action on.
And the final thing
we do is share.
We share.
We help people share
the experiences
that they have with
social services.
So that the community
can improve overall,
and other people can know,
what are the best resources out
there?
And what are the
best services that
might help them improve
their lives, as well?
So that, in a nutshell,
is what One Degree is.
And I look forward to
answering questions.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
I just am really
curious about the
eligibility thing.
You might have said this.
But do you work directly with
nonprofits to figure that out?
Because it's not published in
a clear way a lot of times.
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah, absolutely.
So we do work with
a lot of nonprofits.
And I can get to that a little
bit more in terms of as a way
to do outreach to people.
But we've taken a
really specific approach
to working with
individuals directly.
So we do work with
nonprofits in some cases
to make sure their information
is correct on One Degree
to really surface and highlight
that eligibility information.
But nonprofits are
not necessarily--
solving the enrollment
and intake process is not
necessarily where
we're starting from.
Maybe one day.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Thanks, Eric.
So Susan, tell us
about Hack the Hood.
SUSAN MERNIT: Sure.
Hi, everybody.
I moved to Oakland from
Silicon Valley in 2008.
And in the past couple
of years, the number
of tech buses going
through the streets,
picking up people to take them
to San Francisco or Mountain
View has really risen.
And one of the things
that I came to realize
is that there are
a lot of people
who live in cities like Oakland
who feel like they're never
going to be able to
get on those buses.
They feel very shut out.
They don't have the education
or the relationships
to get them jobs in technology.
And they don't really
know how to get them.
And there's a lot
of hopelessness
and a lot of frustration.
We started Hack the
Hood as a program that
could work with low income
youth of color in Oakland
and cities like it,
teach them really
basic web development skills,
search engine optimization,
how to list businesses in
Google, local places, maps,
and directories.
And we take those
skills, and the kids
go out and get local
businesses online.
And help bridge
the economic divide
by making people who might not
show up in a search on a map
suddenly appear
when you're looking
for them on your mobile phone.
The kids are doing real
world, hands on learning.
And once they kind of have
some of that under their belt,
we take them to companies
like Google and Facebook
and to small
startups, where they
can meet people of color who
are working in tech careers
and understand that there are
so many different kinds of jobs
that they could train
to be qualified for.
It's a pretty impactful program.
But it's also a
very young program.
And it's a program that's
very much made in partnership.
We collaborate with
the City of Oakland,
who was our first funder.
We work with all
kinds of chambers
of commerce and business
improvement districts,
neighborhood associations,
merchant groups.
Volunteers block walked,
help collect merchant data
from people who don't
have easy web access.
And it's really
kind of, you know,
the village trying to come
together and change both
the prospects for these youth
of color, a real diversity play,
but also really help these
low income businesses.
So as a winner of the
Google Impact Challenge,
this was a very
exciting time for us.
Because we now have the
capability to expand.
And we want to expand
into the greater Bay Area,
and over the next
two years, reach
5,000 youth and as many
as 25,000 businesses
through our program.
So if you're interested
in learning more,
I'd love to talk to you more.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Thanks.
Susan, you clearly have
such a passion for Oakland.
But I know you're not
a Bay Area native.
Can I ask how you
made it your home?
SUSAN MERNIT: I'm one
of those people who
moved to Oakland because
I came from Brooklyn.
I moved from New York
to Silicon Valley
to work at AOL/Netscape
back in 2000.
And always thought I
would like Oakland,
but didn't want to
make the commute.
And then when I started
doing my own startups--
I had a Tech Stars
company that crashed--
I moved to Oakland
because it was cheap
and I thought I would like it.
And I kind of fell in
love with the city.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Wonderful.
Thank you.
Stefan?
STEFAN NILSSON: Yeah, thanks.
It's great being here.
Thanks everybody for joining.
I know it's late in the day.
So by way of
introduction, I want
to share with you
a statistic that I
think is pretty startling.
When you look at the
US today, only 8%
of kids from a low
income background
can be expected
to earn a college
degree by their mid-20s.
That's in stark contrast to 82%
of kids from a higher income
background.
So if we just think of
that gap for a second,
think of the loss potential
that that represents,
that's the issue that we're
trying to solve at Beyond 12.
And that's the space
that we work in.
Obviously, graduating
or not graduating
has a huge impact
for the students
and for the students' family.
But in addition to
that impact, that
has a tremendous
impact on our economy.
In California alone,
by 2025, if we
continue on the
current trajectory,
we're expected to be 2.3
million degrees short
of what our economy
is expected to need.
So there's a tremendous impact
not only on a personal level,
but for our economy, as well.
So what Beyond 12 does is that
we've created a set of services
and a set of tools that we
use to try to bridge this gap.
And when we look at the data
and the service gap that
exists, what we find is that
we really have a broken system.
We have an educational
pipeline where
high schools don't
talk to colleges.
And we have no way
to actually track
what's happening to our
kids through that pipeline.
And the impact of
that is that our kids
are falling through the cracks.
The impact is that our
kids aren't graduating,
as the data clearly tells us.
And what we're trying
to do is kind of bridge
that gap and help high
schools and colleges
provide the academic, the
social, the emotional support
to these kids to make
sure that they're
able to actually graduate.
And fundamentally, what we do at
Beyond 12, we do three things.
We track kids.
So when kids get into college,
we track their performance,
and we feed that data
back to high schools.
And what that does
for the high schools,
that allows them to understand
how efficiently they're
actually preparing
kids for college.
What we're seeing today is
that we're seeing high schools
graduating kids that
are college eligible
but not actually college ready.
So we track kids.
We connect kids.
We connect kids to other
students on campus,
to important campus
resources that's
going to help them
be successful.
And then last but not
least, we coach kids.
So for our low
income freshmen, we
provide a personal coach for
the first two years of college,
allowing them the
support system that they
need to be able
to be successful.
We believe, obviously, that
this has a tremendous impact
and potential for a
tremendous impact on the kids
that we are able to
work with directly.
But equally as important, we're
able to have a systemic impact,
both on the high schools from
which our kids are coming
and the colleges that
they're enrolling in,
and that they're
currently attending.
So in a nutshell,
that's Beyond 12.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I know
you're Bay Area based.
But I don't know if your
students or users are mostly
in the Bay Area?
Or are you trying to solve this
nationally, internationally?
STEFAN NILSSON:
Yeah, great question.
So Beyond 12 is a Bay Area
based and founded organization.
We do operate on a
national level today.
So we actually have a minimal
office in Atlanta, as well.
But we're a national
organization.
So we support kids
who come from school
systems across the country.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Thank you.
Does anyone know what
that clapping is outside?
There's a comedy show next door?
And you guys chose
to be here with us?
Yeah, that deserves
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
That's amazing.
We're going to
make them jealous.
That's what's about
to happen here.
OK, so we are at a
developer conference.
And these people in the room are
probably amazing technologists.
So I'd like to talk a
little bit about how you're
using technology to
address your issue,
and maybe talk about what's
unique in your approach,
starting with Susan.
SUSAN MERNIT: Sure.
Does anybody know
teenagers in big cities
who don't have smartphones?
Everybody who comes into our
program has a smartphone.
But most of the youth
that we work with
think of themselves as
consumers of technology,
not as producers of technology.
To them, the kind of apps
that we look at every day
are kind of a black box.
And they're the audience for it.
So part of what we're trying
to do is change the equation
and teach kids how
they can use basic web
tools to become producers.
So what we start off
with is very simple.
It's really the Google Apps
suite and tools like Weebly
that are drag and
drop website builders.
But we use that as a gateway
to make them feel successful,
make them interested in
other kinds of programming.
So we have a mentor program.
We have a lot of local
programmers from Oakland
and the Bay Area who really
want to help our kids understand
all the different
kinds of programming
languages, the different kinds
of assistants you can work
with, what APIs are,
what's a code review.
And help them get from our
program, which is a feeder,
into deeper kinds of involvement
with other kinds of tech.
So we look at ourselves
as a great place to start.
We want to help move
them along the way,
whether it's to a certificate
in project management,
or it's actually starting to
study a serious programming
language and get the skills
to work in the industry.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Thank you.
I'm going to ask the
same question of Eric
about One Degree.
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah.
It's a great question.
There are online
directories that exist.
Google exists as
a search engine.
There's also a pretty well
known directory called 2-1-1.
I don't know if anyone
here has heard of it.
It's basically an online
directory of social services.
There are other
directories out there.
And they're mostly geared
towards social work
professionals.
I sort of alluded to
this in the intro.
But they're geared
towards people
who already know
how to navigate.
They can see an
organization and already
tell you a little bit
about what that might be,
how that might benefit you.
And so what we did
with One Degree
was take a very
unique approach, which
was to create a user aligned,
consumer web product,
and eventually smartphone apps,
for help seekers themselves,
not for the intermediary,
not for the caseworker
or the social worker.
And so that's the
big differentiator.
And the way we do that
is, or one of the ways
in which we get at
that, is besides just
having very high quality,
we hope high quality,
engaging experiences, it's
also a part of the content
that we serve.
And so we sort of saw
that in the intro slide.
But we get at that through,
instead of showing you
information, like if
you were searching
for help with a pregnancy
or a pregnancy test,
rather than giving you back
the organization, Saint Anthony
Foundation, we would give you
back, get a pregnancy test.
And here's where to go.
And here's when to do
it, and in this case,
what the next steps to take are.
And in this case, it would
be to go to the clinic
during office hours.
So we give you really
specific information
that's geared towards consumers
and not professionals.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
It's really nice
to hear you
articulate who you're
trying to help so
clearly, the help seeker.
Because I think that's
something we all struggle with,
is defining the user.
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah, absolutely.
And that isn't to
say that there's not
a place at One Degree for
nonprofit professionals
and social work professionals.
And there absolutely is.
And in fact, we have
a large user base
of people in local
nonprofits using One Degree.
And it's hopefully growing.
But they're using
it as something
that they can use along
with their clients.
Because the content is so
ready for their clients.
It doesn't need
to be translated,
doesn't need to be put
into layman's terms.
It's already ready
for help seekers.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
And Susan, I, this morning,
just whapped my microphone
like 1,000 times.
I try not to do it
anymore, but it's amazing.
Stefan, I'd like to ask
you a different question.
Now I can see that I might
have screwed that up.
STEFAN NILSSON:
That's all right.
STEPHANIE HANNON: But
Eric did a great answer.
So I'm just going to ask
you the same question.
Can you talk about how
you're using technology
to address your issue?
STEFAN NILSSON: Sure, yeah.
I'll stick to the script, right?
So I think--
STEPHANIE HANNON: I
only have one job.
So far, so good, right?
STEFAN NILSSON: No, I
think Eric did a great job.
So when we look at, if we
think back to our model,
one of the key components of
our model is the coaching model.
So the coach that we provide
to our low income freshmen
for the first two years of
their college experience,
it's a great model.
We know that it works.
Data tells us that it works.
But by definition, it's
a high touch model.
And so therefore, it
doesn't scale very well.
So even if we would like to,
it's not really realistic
for us to try to provide
that model or that coach
to every kid in the US who
might actually need it.
So the kids that we work
with, by way of background,
oftentimes, they're the
first kids in their family
or their circle of friends or
sometimes even their community
that go to college.
So they don't have that
kind of social network
and social support network and
support system that maybe you
enjoyed or I enjoyed or you
guys in the audience enjoyed,
parents who went to
college and can prepare you
for what that experience
is going to be like.
And there's a lot of stuff
they need to understand.
There's a stark difference
in the academic requirements,
academic deadlines, things to
think about from the skills
and behaviors that
you need to pick up.
So it's this big hairy problem.
So what we're doing,
with help from Google,
is that we're creating
the My Coach app.
And what that does, or what
we're trying to do with that,
is take this big hairy
problem and synthesize it down
into actionable items, things
that students can take action
on, deadlines that
they can work towards,
skills that they can
acquire, behaviors
that they can learn that's
going to ultimately allow
them to be successful
in college.
And by doing that,
what we're doing is
we're centrally creating
a virtual coach.
And we're able to provide
that proven coaching
model to a scale of students,
so a critical mass of students
that really need it.
So super excited about that.
And then of course,
on the back end,
we have an analytic
system that allows
us to track how well those
kids are doing compared
to the kids who were receiving
the personal coaching model,
and also what parts of the
application or that experience
actually works, what we
need to double down on
and what we need to maybe
jettison on and get better at.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Thank you so much.
STEFAN NILSSON: No problem.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
So Eric, I would
love to share some of your
learnings with this audience.
What are some
misconceptions developers
might have when they develop
for users like yours?
ERIC LUKOFF: It's
a great question
that we've amply prepared for.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Right.
I just thought of that.
ERIC LUKOFF: So we actually
have a lot of misconceptions
that we face.
And one of the
biggest is, and I'll
let you in on a little bit
of a secret in the tech
industry, which is that poor
people use the internet.
And we actually have these
slides that I have prepared.
And you can see that about
50% of low income families
access the internet somewhere.
So that's already a
pretty high volume
of people who we know
are in this market.
And then we also know that a
large percentage of low income
families or low income
individuals have smartphones.
So I think it's about
47% of individuals
under 49 years of age
have a smartphone.
And then that
number jumps to 77%
when we talk about
under 29 years old.
So we're talking
about a huge market
of people who are low income,
who have smartphones, who
are digital ready, and who
don't have tech products that
are built for them, in a sense.
And so I think those are
two major misconceptions
about access.
Another misconception
that we face a lot,
or maybe it's a judgment, is
technology really something
that a low income
individual should invest in?
I mean, if you
can't find food, why
would you need a smartphone?
And I think that's something
that we face a lot.
And I think we should be
really clear here in this room
that technology is not a luxury.
It's a necessity.
We use our smartphone.
We use the internet to
access government services,
to apply for jobs, to manage
our bank accounts, to pay bills,
to learn.
It's a necessity
in today's world.
And so I think that's
another big thing
that we face a lot in
terms of misconceptions.
STEPHANIE HANNON: So how do
you apply these learnings
as you're developing One Degree?
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah.
These are great questions.
I would say we start
from a perspective
that technology is a
really important tool.
And we want to build first class
technology, first class web
experiences.
Because it's so critical.
It's not nice to have.
It's not like a, let's
build a cool user experience
for user experience sake.
It's a necessity, because
it's already really difficult
to find help.
It's already really difficult
to get the resources
that some families need.
And so it's a
requirement that we
build excellent
experiences for them.
Not only is it
because they should
be excellent for everybody
regardless of your income
level, but also because it makes
it easier to actually get help.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Thank you.
So Stefan, I'd like to ask
you about the major pitfalls
with regard to technology
and social change.
I'm sure it's something
we can all comment on.
But how have you experienced it?
STEFAN NILSSON: Yeah.
It's an important question.
I think if you ask
everybody in the audience,
I'm sure everybody has
a different answer.
But I think one
thing that I see,
or a couple of things
that I see often
is, particularly with
technology changing so fast,
we have a tendency to
believe that the new device
or the new app or the new
solution or the new paradigm,
big data, whatever
it may be, is going
to solve the things that
we're struggling with today.
They're going to be able to
affect the change that we
want in the social arena.
And I think by and large,
that's not really true.
To have systemic
change, you really
need to be able to change human
behavior and human practices.
And in order to do that, we
need to bring to the table
the folks who we're
trying to solve for.
So similar to what
Eric is doing, really
understand what their
lives are about, and really
understand how they're
using technology
or they're using devices
or apps, et cetera,
and kind of get
at their problems
through those channels.
And too often, we work
around these groups.
Too often, we're
not putting them
at the center of
what we're creating.
And we kind of sit and
we congratulate ourselves
on how smart we
are and how nice we
are to help all these
wonderful people out there
who need our help.
But we're not bringing them in.
And we're not putting
them at the center
of what we're creating.
And I think that's
super important.
And that's the
only way that we're
going to be able to
get systemic change,
if they're part of
the process, if they
have a voice, a
strong voice that
allows them to
feel like they have
agency in what we're creating.
So I think those are
some of the things
that I see as challenges
with technology
affecting social change.
SUSAN MERNIT: I just want to add
that I think that user centered
design is a principle that's
really important to work
with with low
income communities.
And that the best apps
and the best tools
are developed in
partnership with the people
that they serve.
And we've learned some
really funny things.
When we first started working
on this project, we were like,
we can just do everything
through our phone
and our tablets and computers.
And we actually
had to use paper.
There were people who
wanted to fill out a form,
and like, that's what they
were comfortable with.
And we ended up
saying, well, if that's
what a certain segment
of our audience wants,
I guess we're going to do that.
It seemed very archaic.
But they were much
more comfortable
filling out a piece of
paper than having somebody
enter information into a tablet.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Eric, did
you want to add something?
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah, I just
wanted to add something.
I think this idea that if
we built it, they will come.
This phenomenal
technology is that we've
solved some amazing world
problem, just doesn't really
happen.
And I think we're all sort
of saying the same thing,
that it's this user
aligned approach
that's really critical.
We're on the ground every
day talking to people,
recruiting people and asking
them questions and asking them
how we could be helpful, and
what's actually useful to you
and what's not.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Yeah.
I think we're
working or struggling
with some of the same
things at Google.
One of our areas is
civic engagement.
So how do you get people to
be interested in the things
happening around them on
their block, their bike
lane, their school, their park?
And the data is
really hard to get,
to even try to expose
that information to users.
But then I don't know if
they're going to be interested.
Like, what if we go to all that
trouble and get all that data?
And I think there's sometimes a
little bit of, if we build it,
they will come mentality.
People are trying to
figure out aggressively
how to test those assumptions.
Sounds like that's a big part
of whatever all of us are doing.
Susan, I would love it
if you could walk us
through a particular challenge
you faced at Hack the Hood.
SUSAN MERNIT: Sure.
One of the challenges
we face at Hack the Hood
is just how thin the margin is
that a lot of our young people
are on financially.
We were very proud
of the idea that we
were building this
virtuous circle where
we could train kids, the
kids work with businesses.
And then we would help them
get more training and more
education.
But our first full
program was last year.
And I had a very sobering
moment about January
when I discovered that of three
of the youth who had enrolled
in college who hadn't
planned to go, two of them
had dropped out.
One was a girl who got pregnant.
And the other dropped out to
support a family member who
needed help, because she was
the only person in her family
who could get a full time job.
So here was one of the best
students in our program,
incredibly bright, working
as an assistant manager
at McDonald's for $8.75 an hour.
And I felt like we'd
really sort of failed her.
Because we didn't
really understand
that getting her to
college and getting a loan
to pay for school
wasn't really enough.
And it made us really
change our program.
We kind of stepped back
and said, how do we
provide better support
beyond the actual boot camp
that we're doing?
Not only to get them
internships and job placements,
but in general.
And what we did is we reached
out to the community colleges.
And now this year, we're
going to say things to kids
like, wow, you're really
good at logistics.
You could go to
Samuel Merritt College
and get a degree in
project management.
And there are
certificate programs
that we could get them into
where if they are working,
they could make
$15 or $20 an hour
and be able to continue
their education.
So that was hard to see that
the safety net was so thin
and that we really
needed to do a lot
more to make them successful.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Thanks
for sharing that story.
Eric, do you have a case
study you could share with us?
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah, I do.
STEPHANIE HANNON: One
of your challenges?
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah.
And this goes back to
actually what we were just
talking about in terms
of user centered design.
So before, this is something
that every product person faces
before you have anything off
the ground, is how complex
do you make the
minimum viable product?
And so before we
started, we did a bunch
of user interviews or
potential user interviews
with people who we thought
might be our target audience.
So I remember really
distinctly talking to one mom
who really made me
realize something, which
was that a lot of low income
families or low income
individuals who
have smartphones,
that segment that we were
talking about earlier, which
is quite sizable, use
smartphones, have them and use
them on a regular basis,
but don't use email.
And so that made us realize that
to require email for signing up
for our service, that would be a
nonstarter for a lot of people.
And it was really
important to us
to be able to serve
a wider market
and include these people into
our membership at One Degree.
So we decided from the get
go, although it definitely
adds some complexity to
a site just starting out,
we decided to
accept registration
with either email
or a phone number.
And then with those people,
we communicate with them
over SMS instead of email.
And so that's just
like a decision
that you have to make when you
realize that the thing that you
have in your head is not quite
aligned with what everyone else
or what the people that
you actually want to serve
had in mind.
STEPHANIE HANNON: And as we
talked about when we met,
as a Gmail PM,
it's hard to hear.
But I understand
it's the reality.
Susan, I'm going to go
back to you for a second.
I think I didn't
give you a chance
to say what those learnings
with those three students,
how did it impact you?
SUSAN MERNIT: It was one of
those teachable moments when
you realize that as well
intentioned as you are,
you really need to do more.
And I know a lot more about
certificates and continuing
education certification now than
I did at this time last year.
And I realize how important
those kinds of relationships
are where we can really pass
these students to people
who will help them get
situated in a way where
they can be successful.
So it takes an investment.
But some of the kids we
worked with who I'm describing
are coming back to work
with us this summer.
And I'm really
committed to making sure
that they don't end up
in this situation again.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Thank you.
And just a few more
questions from me.
And then I want to
remind you, we're
going to invite you
guys to ask questions.
It can be about the content
of their work, their careers,
why they do what they do, or
even being a part of the Bay
Area Impact Challenge, what
that experience was like.
So be thinking.
Stefan, I'd like
to go back to you
and say, what can nonprofits
learn from developers?
And what can developers
learn from nonprofits?
Seems appropriate
for this audience.
STEFAN NILSSON: Yeah.
So I think when I look
at it from the experience
that we've had at
Beyond 12, I think
one of the things that we've
been able to kind of impart
on Beyond 12 is kind of what
we maybe think of as developers
on a day to day basis,
which is this quantifiable
and data driven approach
to problem solving.
Something works or it doesn't.
And it's valuable or it's not.
And then you jettison
or you double down.
Whereas in, at least
in our case, and I
think in the nonprofit
sector in general,
it's easy to kind of get focused
on an individual or a community
of individuals and
not think about,
how do you bring it to scale?
How do you optimize?
How do you find ways to provide
the services and the help
that you want to provide
to a larger group of people
that really need it?
So I think that's
something that we've
been able to learn from
the developer community
at Beyond 12.
And vice versa, I
think as I try to help
Beyond 12 scale their services,
we talked about the coaching
model and how we're trying to
scale that through the My Coach
application.
I do a lot of things to try
to streamline and optimize
and make sure that
it kind of gets
to as many people as possible.
And it's easy in that process
to make generalizations.
It's easy to forget that
behind all the things
that you're working on,
there's a real person.
There's a young woman
trying to go to college
and trying to graduate.
And they're trying to
navigate FAFSA applications
and drop or add deadlines
and so on and so forth.
And you can't forget
that as you try your best
to optimize and bring to scale.
You've got to remember that
there's somebody who's, maybe
even their entire family's hopes
and dreams are on that person's
shoulder.
And they're just trying to
get through the next semester.
And so I'd come
back to something
that I think has been a
recurring theme here, which
is technology is not enough.
It's not just about the app.
It's not just about the coach.
There's a human factor to all
of these things that really have
to be addressed and thought
about and considered
in everything that we do.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I
was very impressed
across all of your stories, how
deeply you guys have invested
in understanding your users
and the human element.
So Eric, I'd love to ask you,
how can developers be useful?
If people are sitting
here, they're inspired,
they want to get involved.
How can they
contribute their skills
in the current ecosystem?
ERIC LUKOFF: And just
to echo what Stefan just
said that goes with this is
that apps are a dime a dozen.
It's like, you can create
an app, that's great.
But to answer your
question, we see
a lot of hackathons
and hack events.
And I would say those
are not useful in terms
of creating systemic change.
Think about it this way.
You have a problem that you're
trying to solve at work.
Think about the hardest problem
that you have at your job
right now, intractable
problem that
will take you weeks, months,
maybe years to solve.
And then having somebody come
in and say, you know what?
I'm going to spend 24
and 48 hours on it.
And then I'm going to create
an app and solve your problem,
and then walk away.
You just wouldn't take
it that seriously.
And I think that's what sort
of goes on at hackathons
when they're for social good.
And I think the intention is
there, but the impact is not.
And I think if you want
to help as a developer,
the best thing to do is plug
into an existing organization
that is doing something, doing
something that you respect
and you admire and you think
is a really important thing.
And ask them how you can be
helpful in helping them build
an infrastructure that is
sustainable and maintainable.
The worst thing to do is
create something and walk away.
And no one's there
to maintain it.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Thanks for sharing that insight.
I think it's unique
since hacking,
especially civic
hacking, are very hot.
Susan, the last
question to you, same.
How can developers be
useful or get involved?
SUSAN MERNIT: I'm actually
a huge fan of civic hacking
and a big admirer
of organizations
like Code for America.
And I think that there's an
incredible need for developers
to help with standardizing
APIs and with pulling data out
of government and a
lot of different kinds
of closed systems so that
people can work with them.
I agree with Eric.
It's kind of a black box.
And if you move to
help in that direction,
people will embrace you.
But I also think that there's
kind of an individual role
that developers can play
in organizations like Hack
the Hood and probably all
of these organizations.
We need people to be mentors.
We need people who made
the journey into tech
and who love what they do to
work with young people of color
who have no idea what it's like
to do those jobs, what it's
like to have the
kind of passion,
but who are really
hungry to find something
that they can do
that's interesting
and that's economically viable.
So I would think about, to what
extent can you share yourself
in a limited way
with a demanding job
by being a mentor, by giving
a talk, by volunteering
at an event.
Find a way that you
can share your passion
and your experience with
somebody for whom you might end
up being a giant influencer and
help really move them forward
into a new kind of career.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Thank you.
So I'd love to open
it up for questions.
There are microphones.
Matthew's going over there.
I see him.
I called on him.
But this should
be a conversation.
So think of the hardest,
toughest questions
you want to ask these panelists.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
First, congratulations
on winning the challenge.
My question's really
one I struggle
with a lot in this sector,
which is the trade off
between scalability and
impact on a personal level,
a direct level.
And I think it's something
where I think technology tends
to be tied up with scalability.
The reason why we
think technology
is a great way to enable, to
make more impact at scale,
but it also sometimes is at
odds with that person to person
interact and the immediacy of
actually helping individuals.
Like you say, sometimes
you're doing just some hacks
to make it happen and help
them out, versus some long term
sustainable, scalable
solution, which
it sounds like the holy grail
and often isn't possible.
How do you deal with that
trade off in your process?
And if you put yourself
on a scale of 1 to 100,
100% being 100% scalability.
And if it's not scalable,
I don't touch it.
And 0 is, all I care
about is helping people.
And really, to be
honest, the technology
is very, very secondary,
or the scalability
is really secondary to me.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
Anyone can answer.
STEFAN NILSSON: Sure.
I'll take a stab.
I think we struggle
with scalability.
And I talked about the My Coach
app and our coaching model,
which is a very high touch model
that doesn't necessarily scale.
And I think Alex, our
founder who is not here
today, we kind of bring
parity to that question.
I'm always challenging
her to jettison things
that is going to not scale.
Because it requires
personal interaction.
Or it requires a people
heavy organizational model,
which is really hard to
sustain when you get to scale.
So I challenge her on,
are areas particularly
and necessarily
need to be there?
Can we do it in a different way?
Can we support something
with technology?
So I kind of bring that
voice to the conversation.
And she brings the voice that I
talked about earlier, which is,
guess what?
These kids come
from a background
where they don't have
the support system.
And a lot of times, I'll
take a very specific example,
we had a student that was
trying to get to college.
And that student's parents
was dissuading that person
from going to college.
Because she was going to be
too far away from her family.
It wasn't a financial issue,
although that certainly
was a struggle.
It wasn't the fact that
they were concerned
about her being able
to be successful.
It's like she was
literally going
to be too far away
from her family.
And these are the kids
that we're trying to help.
And there are kids, and they're
falling through the gaps today.
So it's a constant clash.
And I can't say that
we found a solution.
But as technology
becomes better,
as it becomes more prevalent,
as kids are able to have access
to devices, data plans that
are affordable, et cetera,
we can provide better
services through technology.
But the challenge, the tension
between being technology
centric and human
centric is always there.
SUSAN MERNIT: We're super
interested in that question.
Because we want to scale from
serving 20 kids in one summer
program to 5,000
kids around the area.
So it's kind of the question
we're grappling with.
And I think there's
no replacement
for human relationships
and human interaction.
You can't just put somebody
in front of a machine
and think you're having the
same quality of experience.
But we're also
talking about people
who are doing everything
on their phone,
including watching videos.
So we're very
interested in the whole
flip the classroom
model and the idea
that we can supplement
the real world
interaction we do
with more videos.
And that things like
Hangouts and Skyping
can be supplements
and good additions
to real world exchange.
So I think we're going
to very much look
at how we can use
those kinds of tools
to do a better job of
getting people ready,
even having to leave behind,
between the real world
human touch
programming that we do.
ERIC LUKOFF: The
only thing I'd add
is that I don't necessarily
think there's a tension.
I think, at least
in our organization,
we actually talk a lot
about the spectrum of users.
So we talk about
people who are really
high need, who really
require a high touch,
personal interaction, and
maybe don't have a smartphone,
don't have a computer, wouldn't
be tech savvy even if they
had one.
And then the other
side of the spectrum
is a single mom working
a minimum wage job,
needs to find help,
but knows what
she's doing on her smartphone.
So this is sort of the spectrum.
And the ideal
member of One Degree
is sort of like over here.
But this part of the population
or this part of our target
market, if you
will, is one we can
reach through intermediaries,
like with personal touch
and through social workers
and social work professionals.
And we very specifically
say we're not
like an automated social worker.
We're never going to
replace social workers.
We're never going to replace
a friend or a person who
can help, or a case manager.
So it's really, I
think we're getting
at that at different ways,
not necessarily in tension,
at least in our case.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
Thanks, Matthew.
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Eric, when you were
talking about the discovery
you guys made of email itself
being kind of an impediment
to some of the people
you were trying to serve,
signing up and
using your tools, it
was kind of surprising to me.
As you know, the
organization I work with,
we build tools to try to bring
voting into the 21st century.
And we're ostensibly trying
to build that for everyone.
But our sign up requires email.
So that occurred to me,
we have that impediment
to low income people
using our tools.
So my question
is, are any of you
aware of good resources
or organizations
or whatever to learn
about things like that?
Either like a sort
of list of things
like that to keep in mind
when you're building tools
like this, or even organizations
that can come in and audit
the technology you're
building to make sure
that it's accessible
to low income people?
ERIC LUKOFF: I don't.
But if you find
one, let me know.
I mean, maybe, you know--
STEPHANIE HANNON: Does anyone?
AUDIENCE: Can I hire
you to come do that?
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah,
I mean, I don't
think that having someone
from the outside come in
and necessarily do
an audit is going
to solve the question
of being user aligned.
I mean, you have to,
obviously you know this,
but just to make
it clear, you have
to do that sort of interviewing
and research for yourself.
Because it's going to be
different for your product
than for ours.
So I think maybe
this is one case
in which that would overlap.
But there's going to
be other stuff that
is going to be really
different, I think.
STEPHANIE HANNON: But maybe
one of the coolest things that
could come out of this
panel is you guys all
get together
afterwards and decide
to put together a
set of resources.
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
You guys connect.
Thank you for the question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
The first questioner had
an interesting question
about scalability of programs
versus personal touch.
And I run, as a side project,
a community nonprofit
called the Obscure
Organization at obscure.org.
And we have one program that's
kind of a public access Unix
system that is
deliberately not scalable.
You have to ask
nicely for an account,
or write a letter on paper
with a self-addressed stamped
envelope.
There's no online sign up form.
Because I can't maintain a
5,000 person online service
in my spare time.
But we had one other program
that did end up scaling,
where I write and then
conducted a series of classes
on MIT Scratch for a local
elementary school program
and after school program.
And I wrote up the lesson plans
for this and the classroom
experience reports,
and published these
under Wikipedia Compatible
Licensing Terms.
And other parents
in the community
took those and ran other
classes in other schools
in the community.
And there were people in the
STEM wing of the local county
public schools who took those
lesson plans and used those
as the basis for
building programs
that they've taught
for the last five years
as a supplementary program.
So sometimes, you
can achieve scale
by just figuring out a template
for other people to do things,
and planting the seed
or something like that.
It's an option.
Because you'd have to have high
touch in a lot of these things.
You can't scale an after
school program for 10 kids
with one person.
But you can, if you
do it right, come up
with ideas that will inspire
other people to continue
the work that you've done.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Amazing.
So just to make sure,
that was an answer
to Matthew's question.
Perfect.
I appreciation you sharing.
That was really wonderful.
I think this will be our
last question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was actually
curious for Beyond 12,
you said you were
feeding some of the data,
like on the students
you've tracked
and stuff, back to
the schools, trying
to close that communication
gap between the colleges
and the primary education.
Have you seen or
have you guys been
able to help drive policy
change in public education
a little bit?
Have you seen schools
changing their curriculum
or programs or
support structures
based on the information
you've been providing them
and the success stories
that you've had?
How is that going?
STEFAN NILSSON:
Yeah, great question.
So I guess the answer to
that would be not yet.
So we're in Year Five
as an organization.
Our first cohort of students
are about to graduate
and are graduating now.
So for the high
school systems that we
have been working with
for that period of time,
we've been feeding
this data back.
One of the things that we don't
have a ton of visibility into
is how they're actually
using that data
and how they're consuming that.
And by extension,
what you're asking
is, how are they
taking that data
and then using that to actually
inform their curriculum
and making changes?
So what we're
focused on right now
is providing the tools for
them to consume the data easily
without having to learn
a lot about analytics
or learn a lot about reporting
and learn a lot about how
to read the statistics,
if you will.
And then the next stage
is going to be, hopefully,
for us to also provide
suggestions on where
are the areas where
they could improve.
I kind of don't want to
speak for Alex, because this
is really her area of expertise.
I don't think we want to be
in the business of telling
high schools how to make
changes and what changes they
should make.
What we want to do is
provide them with the data
and help them
understand the data.
And then let them
draw their conclusions
about what they need
to do from a curriculum
or process and a
model perspective.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
I think as the moderator, I
get to ask the last question.
And you guys can choose to all
answer it, or just one of you
can answer it.
But I think coming from
the Google mindset,
sometimes I'm obsessed
with data and metrics
and what's measurable
in terms of our impact.
But somebody really smart
I met here yesterday
said to me, not everything
that counts can be counted.
Not everything that
counts can be counted.
So I wonder if
you guys will talk
about how you think
about your impact,
and does it need
to be measurable?
STEFAN NILSSON: I'll
take a stab at it.
From the Beyond
12 perspective, I
think one of the biggest
challenges that we have is,
there are very
difficult, or areas
that are non-quantifiable in
our interactions with our kids
that tells us, that are
kind of markers and signals
that tells us that maybe
they're not doing that great.
Maybe they're not able
to find the support they
need to be successful
in college, for example.
But they're
non-quantifiable data.
They're not data
points that show up
on a report from a data feed.
They're conversational.
When our coaches
talk to the kids,
and they're at home by
themselves on a Friday night,
that tells us that they haven't
really created a community.
They haven't found
that support system.
You have non-quantifiable
data points.
We do our best to
take those things
and put it into our model, that
allows us to kind of figure out
where kids are and
what they're doing.
But like you said, not
everything that counts
can be counted.
It's difficult.
And that's one of the
challenges that we're
facing as we're trying to
scale from a human high touch
model to a technology model.
How do we catch those things?
How do we make sure that those
things are counted somehow?
SUSAN MERNIT: We don't
think that the value
of human experiences
can all be measured.
And we know how
important that is.
But we're actually
very data driven.
Because one of our
axioms is, if you
don't know how to measure it,
you may not be ready to do it.
I think that it's
really true that you
can think about how to measure
a chart just about anything.
So I hate the idea of
being a lean organization
and being busy, and feeling
like you're so busy.
But what is the impact
you're really having?
So we think a lot about,
what's smart measurement?
And what are the
measurements that we
can measure that
actually are viable?
So one of our goals for next
year is to have at least 50%
of our youth not
only in education
but in some form of internship.
And you know, that's not 100%.
But it's a good number.
And I think it's
really important
to come up with measurements
that aren't only about what
people did, but ways
to measure the impact.
How do you tell
what the impact is?
And that's where you get
into that human experience
or that values thing that
you can't necessarily
attach a hard number to.
Yet you have to find
some, in my opinion,
you have to find
some equivalency.
Or you run the risk that
maybe you're just being busy,
and you're not actually
doing everything you could.
ERIC LUKOFF: Yeah.
And I would just echo that.
I mean, I think of
course, we can't
measure the whole
of human experience.
But for us, it's critical.
We have to measure
what we do, especially
as a very new organization.
We won't get a second
chance to do it
if we can't measure our
results or our impact.
We have very limited
funding, thankfully a bit
more, thanks to Google.
But we're very new.
And so we need to measure
everything that we do.
And if anything that
we're doing during the day
doesn't in some way
affect the core metrics
that we care about, then
we usually don't do it.
Not because it's not important,
not because it wouldn't
have some ancillary benefit,
but because as an organization,
you also have to approach
it with humility.
We have one thing that we're
going to try to do really well.
We're not going to try to do all
these other things really well,
too.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Well, it's been my huge
honor to sit up here
with the best and brightest
of the Bay Area nonprofits.
I am, I think, allowed to say,
give you guys a sneak peek,
that we're going to
be launching an Impact
Challenge in
Australia next week.
We have one currently
under way in the UK.
The application's
already closed.
But voting will happen soon.
And we hope to be able to
bring them to many more places.
And it'd be wonderful,
amazing if we
saw some of your work
in there someday, too.
So thanks for being here, and
enjoy the last few minutes
of I/O.
[APPLAUSE]